yep so hello everyone know and thanks
coming in next to Siobhan in the
organizers as well for allowing me to
talk appreciate it and I'm it's also
good to be here at zalando as well I
come to a good few talks here so it's
great to finally be able to have the
chance to listen yeah
so I'm sure everyone kind of knows what
Dublin bikes is they've been around for
a good few years now they're also quite
common in many cities around the world
so for anyone who's maybe not familiar
with them not from Dublin it's just
Dublin's public like scheme so you can
pay a subscription sorry you can pay a
subscription whether an annual
subscription or I think a weekend one
and you could add to use the service so
there are 99 stations and run the city I
think it's actually just one around the
corner there's about 1,500 or more bikes
and around 42,000 annual subscriptions
so it's pretty busy associate the times
which is sorry this the microphone
doesn't really like me or maybe doesn't
like Dublin bikes so yeah so it gets
pretty busy at times so that kind of
brings onto my problem in a moment and
the most important thing for this
project and the talk is that there's
real-time data for all the stations
available by an API and also this data
is available through Creative Commons as
well so you're free to use it and adapt
it as you wish so my problem started
about a few years ago so I live down in
Wrath mines and this is a picture taken
from Google Street View of my local
station up in Portobello so I thought it
was quite funny that I didn't even have
to go up and take a picture when it was
empty Google did it for me it's
completely empty most the time and I'm
just trying to get to uni in the
mornings it's kind of frustrating oh did
you end up getting the bus so yeah not
so useful we didn't really get much on
my subscription back then so my
motivation was really to kind of find
times where you know when is a good time
to get its go and get a bike really
because he usually were gone by that 9
o'clock I might be going there so my
girlfriend said I think the natural
question is like just why don't you get
up earlier and so I said you know no I
can solve this with Python and data and
the spirit of this evening I'm quite
lazy as well so
I basically set around collecting laser
data using the from the API now I go
into more detail on that in a moment so
that's gonna be part one of the talk
part 2 and on which is going to be kind
of on what I found so you know what kind
of insights that I find there's
commitment machine learning friend in
there as well more generally though
we're seeing a lot of these API become
available now I know you can get a
transport in other cities and bikes as
well other cities but there's a there's
a wealth of data out there and it's sort
of it's around transport and you know
the future of smart cities so I should
gave a talk similar to this one in
Belfast last week and the theme was all
about smart cities and the explosion of
data what we might be able to do is that
do with that finally I hope as well I
said before it could be a template if
you were to use for their own project so
it's all when cities and data science
and how might be able to use the data
that's available to ask questions of the
authorities and and you know quite a bit
insight into how our cities are
functioning so that brings me to part
one which is around gathering the data
so I have a Raspberry Pi saying at home
there's Eric I think he's my friend and
the audience here said that I would
never use it
so I'm fun able to say actually did you
find the caduceus for it if there's a
API which you can get the data from
which I mentioned which is City Bikes
API and so using the Raspberry Pi I set
up a short Python script to scrape the
date from there every two minutes now
going to be about the data format in
just a moment as well so I was able to
collect this overnight as so they
protect this every two minutes build up
a little table for how many bikes for
each station the different signs in the
day and then overnight at 1:00 in the
morning I just upload that to an s3
bucket and this is a bit more about the
kind of other data that's coming from
the API so we have explained out in a
JSON format so got an example on the
left-hand side there so bikes 15 got the
station name Fenian street few more
details about the position as well it
should be important later when we come
to map in this and it's all a timestamp
and so we basically collect all that
date every two minutes and throw it into
a table of that on the right and we just
keep sticking on the end the day is
fairly basic as well for Dublin we only
really have how many bikes are at each
station we don't really have information
bike user level which some other cities
you provide and I think it's been a few
privacy issues around that so yeah maybe
that's maybe the dubbin situation don't
say bad after all
so then with Dee said about how I
scripted this a lot beginners are we
wondering how the hell do you do this
obviously there's a lot of libraries
imported which always helps pythons good
for that so main libraries are used for
the scraping at the Jason requests so
request is for like HTTP requests like
web scraping and stuff like that request
is quite good for that as well the main
library that I found useful for this
project with something called pandas
this is for it's a data manipulation
library I'll show you a few examples of
how I used that in a moment
but I'm official data scientist it's
pretty much my bread and butter so it's
a really really good one to learn if you
think again going into data analysis of
data science or any kind of data project
pandas is fantastic for that when I was
scraping the weather data I use a local
PI W API which is a Python weather API
allow me to get the data from Yahoo
weather and I think a few other weather
eight noise as well so I had real-time
weather day at Dublin didn't end up
actually using that for anything just
yet but you know if I was kind of
they're making the effort to scrape all
that data might as well get weather as
well so for the overnight bit was fairly
straightforward I used little bash
script for this so use AWS cly which is
the command-line interface for AWS and
you can just write a short script like
i'm linux or on a mac or probably
windows as well you can push this daily
csv oh is building up to the s3 bucket
and you can share your both jobs to run
on the raspberry pi using them as cron
and basically it's sat by my sofa from
january i forgot about it and i
remembered again in august so I have a
lot of data there that's seven or eight
months or so worth of data so every two
minutes so it's quite a lot there so on
a practical note there's I guess
something to mention around resampling
time series so this is a bit of a dry
topic so don't apologize for that but it
might be interesting for anyone who's
handling fine series so the problem is
is when you schedule turn every two
minutes isn't run exactly every two
minutes and it's not the way I did it
probably there is a way to make it a bit
more precise but you look at the
left-hand side I've got this time
so 14 Oh - OH - and the one that's
supposed to be exactly two minutes later
actually just a couple of seconds too
late
looking at the bikes at Union Street
when you have all this data available
you can use something called resampling
this is for it's kind of like a filling
in gaps or interpolating or maybe you're
trying to create a very precise
structure for your data which was my
main the main thing I was trying to do
with it
so you can convert what you've got on
the left-hand side there which is
probably quite awkward to work with and
obviously as time goes on if you look at
the day after this you know this like
time difference is just gonna compound
and get worse and worse so it's makes it
much easier to just use this for
sampling method you get something like
on the right hand side they're nicely
structured every minute I've got a
measurement and I've used this a short
bit of code there as well that we should
do that transformation so I was saying
before use pandas it's my bread and
butter this is a great example of how
it's very good it's very easy to do this
sort of stuff and so you haven't used it
before and you work with data I
definitely give it a look make it look
easier so now all the day has been
collected once we want a bit of analysis
so coming back to my question is how
early do I have to wake up to get a bike
at Portobello harbour unfortunately for
me it's extremely early and probably bit
too early to be honest are sick to the
bus so if we look at the graph here on
the x-axis we have time between midnight
on one night and spanning all the way to
the following midnight so I built this
by you taking an average over every
single weekday in the dataset on the
y-axis there we've got the capacity of
the station and in terms of how full it
is so it's nearly a hundred percent all
the bikes are there
zero percent there's nothing there so
you can see by about 8 o'clock I'm out
of luck really I've got to get there
pretty early I think an interesting
point about this is displaying the
experience where we're often findings
and no bikes there at all you can see on
this graph it's not actually quite 0
this probably run 10% during the middle
of the day I think this could be do with
the weather when it rains people don't
only want to cycle I could I think that
might be possible explanation like I
said I haven't had time to actually look
I have the weather data but I probably
need to do live analysis around that so
anyway not good news to me and getting
to college in the morning but we can do
a lot more with that though I have
measurements going back about seven or
eight months for all the stations in
Dublin since a lot I can do with that so
for example we can look at the system
profe up the average weekday so on the
x-axis we have the same thing again just
an average weekday bit like two midnight
and the y-axis we have the system usage
in some very kind of badly defined
arbitrary units basically the bigger the
bigger the curve the more busy i'm i've
defined the system to be so you can see
peak times well commuting times eight or
nine in the morning and then we're
looking five o'clock ish in the evening
there's a peak in the middle the day
which i think is quite interesting as
well i surprised by that i imagine as
people go into lunch maybe they go into
meetings in the afternoon going to meet
friends and they just going home for the
day so yeah that was a little bit
interesting you look at weekends as well
sharing a bath different profile so yep
so far is fairly simple i want to look
at me people were deeply into this
though and so this graphed a complete
mess i know bear with me i'll make my
point so again on the x-axis we had this
time the average weekday the usage of
the bike station for the day i exist ask
again so i've plotted all nine to nine
stations on this graph and you can see
you know it's not particularly
insightful at first but my argument is
if you squint and you look kind of you
can kind of see there's maybe different
groupings of station profiles it would
kind of make sense that stations that
are on the outside of town
they give me used for people people
commuting into work in the mornings and
we know from the Portobello harbor that
seems to be a that would have a big dip
in the middle day they're probably
similar stations would fit that pattern
and you can say they're opposite
stations as well where they may be in
the middle of town and these are the
depository for bikes coming into the
city and so maybe there are two
different profiles there maybe there are
more and i want to do the investigation
into this and see you know what can i
turn up
what's interesting so easily depart free
and they said this is all around
clustering a time series so i want to
digress slightly just to introduce you
to like a fairly simple algorithm i
doing best to explain it is probably
then
enough times for experience before but I
give you a general gist of it so imagine
we have the data on the right side there
so we've got two dimensions and a bunch
of points are scattered around so I'm
gonna use a method called k-means
clustering now so k-means
aims to partition all this data into K
different groups so it could be one
well one group wouldn't be very helpful
it could be two could be three it could
be more
this is called an unsupervised learning
problem because we don't actually know
how many groups that really are we're
trying to ask the algorithm to figure
this out for us and so it can be quite
nuanced depending on the type of problem
you're working on for a simple example
you could say looking at that as a human
they're you know they're two groups
before if you're gonna be controversial
I guess you could say three as well two
at the top one at the bottom k-means
clustering is extremely easy to
implement with pythons scikit-learn
so some of you might know about that I'm
psychic learn is pythons machine
learning library so it makes a lot of
these algorithms like k-means or you
know simple regression and
classification algorithms they're very
easy to implement they're easy to work
with
so those reply came into that last data
set and I asked it ok can you find me
two groups in in my in my distribution
of points it looks something like this
so we have a red group at the top and
the blue group at the bottom and so the
X's are designating the kind of center
of the cluster and so points on assigned
to their the nearest the nearest cluster
Center there they are to the casket for
K equals four again like I said you can
pick any any number for K so the K
equals four get something slightly
different
so we zoom into something like how do
you exactly decide how many clusters you
have because surely for my problem with
Dublin bikes we're trying to cluster
time series it's quite difficult problem
I've said before if you squint and look
maybe you have to but that's not very
quantitative or not very rigorous so the
method called the elbow method so I'll
just go into a bit of detail here so I
think it's very simplistic and we see
why in a moment so it's a heuristic
approach just a posh word for it's a
rule of thumb basically you kind of look
at things and if things of we yeah you
just look at things so you calculate sum
of the squared errors which is the
average squared distance between each
observation and it's assignment cost
descent
troit rich k-value and this is always
gonna decrease as well and basically
when you graph this like on the right
hand side you're gonna look for the kink
so on the y-axis we have this this sum
of squared errors and the x-axis we have
a number of clusters so I think the kink
is indicated there by the arrows at the
elbow point is where K equals 4
basically this means that if we're
trying to add any more clusters from
cake was for it so it really gonna
substantially improve the clustering
using this using this sum of squared
errors metric so the problem is when you
actually apply that to real world data
it does never work
almost never anyway I'm sure so yeah
lesson learned don't really rely on it
please you can be a lot more rigorous
than that though here I used something
called silhouette scores
so the approaches are a little bit more
complicated but still I think fairly
easy to understand really it's just a
school between minus 1 and 1 again
you're gonna graph this with your
different K values so +1 is very good
it's great minus 1 is pretty bad when we
go back to the drawing boards and 0
suggests you've got classes that are
overlapping so we really want to get
into the mass but it's not too
complicated but I'll skip over it anyway
so we compute the average of this so X
square over all observations and then
basically we're gonna pick the K which
gives the highest score so I've done it
on the right hand side there the data
that we have you can see cake was to
give the biggest silhouette school it's
about point 43 which isn't great let's
be honest but you know I'll take it
in sukazi we apply K equals 2 to our
data set and I think this is kind of the
you know where things get bit more
insightful so when I asked the k-means
algorithm to take the data that i've
gathered and apply cake was to comes up
with these two profiles so again this is
the average weekday usage and I've got
two different profiles I got my green
one on my red one some a green one looks
a bit like Portobello before where you
know people are using it to commute into
the city they've taken bikes from it
it's leaving it empty during the day and
we've got the red group there as well
which exhibits the opposite trends as
the repository for all these bikes this
is a closed system we have a finite
number of bikes bikes have to go between
the other unless they go thrown in the
river hope he doesn't happen too often
anyway we have two very distinct
groupings there and get a bit more with
the mapping you can see there is extreme
weathers
you know there's a massive divide in
there's massive spatial segregation how
the the stations are dotted around the
map so if I'm the green ones were the
ones that people use a usual commuting
in and the red ones be the kind of
impose a treat of that so you can see
there's a massive spatial segregation
going on there just quite interesting it
really is highlight kind of there where
people are living where people are going
to work and I guess it's biased by the
the actual people who have subscribed to
it as well and so I created this map
it's an interactive map as well it did
host it online
I used a library called Bo Liam which is
a Python wrapper for leaflet TS which is
really really good folium as well as
great it makes doing the easy definitely
encourage you if you have any mapping
problems definitely give it a look I was
blown away with this how I have good
stuff looks really for someone who are
definitely done any Java Script so it
made my life a lot easier as well Open
Street Map for the mapping as well it's
quite good resource but I originally did
this actually with cake was three
similar because I thought it looked
cooler so again we have a two profiles
from before the green and the red
profile there so I've thrown another one
for the blue ones remember the the using
the silhouette scores K equals freeze
probably not the most scientifically
rigorous incorrect way of doing it but
you know it's my personal project so I
get to choose so now the blue one kind
of doesn't fit either it's kind of
pretty much steady through the day and I
will kind of show a plot of how old the
station is compared to their there are
assigned profiles as well in just a
moment so when you go to plot this this
is what I thought was very cool you
still have that spatial segregation
going on
okay there's probably a few there's a
red one that kind of on the north side
there around some blues but you sort of
the segregation effect going on do you
think it's really surprising and really
really cool so to say how good it is I
know where the metrics before it's also
good to take a look at your data as well
see how you're doing so I'm left hand
side we've got
the green station so we had 46 stations
the 99 are assigned to the green one so
I've indicated with the dark green line
the the kind of the archetype or profile
you know the the cluster centroid for
the green type stations and with the you
can actually see that yeah so the faint
green lines yep they did come out okay
so the faint green lines are from all
the others for most 46 Asians so you can
see from eyeballing it yeah that's not
bad you know it's pretty good we
definitely see that there's a big tight
band of them especially in the morning
and then in the evening it kind of
definitely stations could diverge and
their patterns a little bit similar
story for the 32 stations for the red
profile as well and for the blue profile
it's all over the shop no surprises
there
I guess it's maybe indicating that it's
not so bad to use cake was three we
definitely have a lot of stations which
didn't fit into either the green or the
red group so that brings me was to a
close really conscious that I might have
been very quick spoke apologize I'm sure
we all he gets to get at the air too and
so was that I learn from the projects
mainly I need to wake up a lot earlier
probably not gonna happen
secondly historical take is really hard
to come by like it's a practical point I
think if you were professional data
scientist you know you usually have a
lot of data available to you for your
company when you come to do this as a
member of the public so she's really
hard to get historical data like you can
you can lodge Freedom Information
requests I did a while ago never heard
back so don't always hedge your bets on
that and so you can with Colet the data
yourself so I hope me showing you how to
you can use a carafe trick pie or even
simpler would just be to use an AWS ec2
instance
efficacy if you want to get really
clever is where you could use AWS lambda
as well which could be another
alternative is well for doing this kind
of job so I had a few comments when
people as well and this brings me back
to what I was saying about being about
citizen data science and and you know
how we can maybe use this data to get
more transparency in our public services
so just read a few them out there for
people who made it back so it's okay
here says very interesting I would use
wix4 more if the distribution was better
typically 0 out of 120 available nearest
office most days and these tweets of
council that as well I think a few
people and myself
completed we tweet to the council we
didn't hear anything back I'm sure they
saw it some bit disappointed but can't
win em all
next one says okay so a new one where
Dublin central district business
district was its where there's blue and
red dots are some the south side or
intercity so I know people probably
their own thoughts throughout that the
next one so Absalom bikes equalize the
balance by moving bikes around the
supposed traffic gets in the way so I do
want to point that out like maybe my
micro my complaints about Portobello
I've been a bit too harsh because at the
end of the day you know they are this is
run with the council and you're the
obviously odd doing it in public
interest as well so I think fair comment
you know it's definitely restrictions
around it's not simply a case of more
bikes more stations so if anyone's
thinking of looking at this project I'll
show the github link in just a moment as
I said the day is available free
Creative Commons comments and my code is
on github as well so it wants to kind of
take a look maybe to see what their own
stations like as well it's okay actually
I share might even think actually so
other things you do the data besides
looking at how your own station is been
as well you can look at things like
resupply times so we have that day and
again
daily every two minutes I was simply
trying take an overview by looking at
the average weekday profiles the effects
of weather i clear to weather day at sea
you do some look at predictive modeling
as well though it's a like a future
project can make like an API is
something like a local station all the
stations can be kind of cool projects as
well it's my obligation as a question of
data science say don't reuse k-means but
time series clustering it did for this
because I thought I got good results but
generally you probably need something
more exotic some good dynamic time
warping which is pretty good didn't have
a chance to implement it with dislike
yeah go okay result some k-means I was
happy with that but definitely thing
about using this for own projects use
k-means easy but also consider something
like dynamic time warping as well I
wouldn't really doing
but it's pretty good it's much more
robust way of clustering time series and
much much more so thank you much for
listening here's things my github and my
Twitter and my blog as well thank you
[Applause]
I'm just trying to get those links up on
the screen there so does anyone have any
questions who would like to start I'm
thinking about dynamic time warping and
you're saying that this might be a
better method can you see anywhere in
the time so one of the things with
dynamic time warping is it's good at
catching time serious words and cycles
right but they might be out of sync so
if two people have the same pace when
they're walking but they're out of sync
or walking at different times it can
still capture that clustering and I'm
wondering did you see that in the
cycling data when you're looking at it
or did you get to eyeball it that much
it's been a while since I looked at it
I've used time at time warping Jim where
job as well like it's pretty robust I'm
currently the best Python implementation
of it actually I don't think it's in
scikit-learn so I open that a rabbit
hole here it's pretty slow okay means is
fairly easy to implement as well and so
I think it's important as well like if
you have and I wouldn't it's kind of
using kind of works well for your
problem I like it did here it's
definitely a good thing but what would
you use euclidean distance or what would
you recommend with dynamic time warping
or even k-means and so like do you have
a go-to distance metric
honestly that's the only one already
used in practice yeah but I guess if it
works that's the point in complicating
it right yeah yep hi thanks for the talk
is very interesting one thing maybe I
missed it
but I didn't see any specific difference
for weekends rather than working days
was the Somme nyet you noticed there
okay that's my SOI to address that
question so I missed a sorry oh so
weekdays versus weekends maybe I skipped
over this pretty quick so the red dash
line there is for weekend okay so you
can see it's a vastly different profile
there like people mainly using around
the afternoons there's definitely no
menu for commuting on a Saturday and
Sunday definitely Albert with minority
of people is where you can look at this
end salads in Sundays they also show
different trends is slightly less each
it's on a Sunday in general yeah and
then another things also is a of the cue
beer so now I read your blog when you
was a couple of months ago it was out
yeah I think like six weeks yeah that
was very good rather the idea was great
but then you know that this made me
think because I was walking to work and
I saw that the word reply replenishing
Bay with the new bikes so there is a
lottery that they've seen more than once
that takes bikes from a place and put
some another one how does that interfere
with your analysis well it's like an
average over such a long time but it was
a nice fact the fact that I forgot about
my my raspberry pi running it's an out
to be a blessing because I think taking
the average over like so many months on
all of the weekdays kind of smooth it
out if you definitely start looking at
the profile of stations on a more
granular level you can definitely see
that another thing you don't get
actually with with this is a bit of like
a small problem with this actually I
think this graph will be
that actually no sorry over to Cabello
so one thing that you will miss with
this as well as because I'm the only
queer in the API over two minutes you do
miss times where whites could come in
and be immediately taken out again which
is you know can you Owen say it's too
much of a problem but it's definitely a
practical issue like the two minutes I
use I think was the kind of API usage
cap any more than that I think they you
know they can't down them on your usage
quite a lot and so there was that
consideration thank you thanks so one
question I have is so one problem is for
you if you get up too late you don't
find bikes there but something that I
have seen is especially in the Science
Gallery one is that people when they
come back from work as well they there
is no no place for leaving the bike
anymore
so they are working with the bike to
find the next Bay and have you found
anything like that and is there anything
in your data as well or is that a
problem that can be solved somehow by
addressing what you have found that's a
really good point it's a problem I had
just a couple of days ago I don't close
any waiting for five minutes so it
wasn't too bad but um it certainly is a
problem it's nothing you can really see
with the data that we don't we only ural
able to see the how many bikes are in
each station so I know some of the other
cities around the world I mentioned in
New York and London so they would have
information about individual bikes so
they'd have a down by the ID going
between which station and the other
station how long it took and I'm sure if
you have detail on the data on that
level you might be able to do something
around that maybe look for abnormally
long travel times then I guess you have
other problems at people stopping at the
shop might cause that method to go
completely out the window it's certainly
a problem like I've noticed remote from
a user point of view and I'm sure dublin
council are aware of it as well like i
wouldn't care to
hypothesize what the correct solution
for that would be I'm sure there are
quite a few I wouldn t I think of any
good ones on the spot maybe like just
more having more that docking stations
could be good maybe they could look at
other cities and see what they've done
to solve the same problem I wanted to
ask whether we have data on on the
individual bags but I think you just
answered this question for so I think
New York and London I think I mentioned
there I think they do or they at least
they used to there was an article a
while ago I think about the privacy
issues surrounding that day if you were
able to you might be able to identify
certain people because they're they have
like unusual habits that can show up in
the data and might be like they might go
to work in a very remote place they
might live in a kind of slight remote
place and they might can you to work at
4:00 in the morning I think there are
maybe issues around around they may have
had to get rid of that making that day
of public perhaps it's only would be
very helpful to have data on that level
but as well like yeah unfortunately
darling we don't have that
scatter
that's effect on this clustering because
you can if there is a station which is
really really far so people will go
there to park the bike because there's
no nearby so that can also affect the
results of this clustering yeah I
definitely agree with that I'll just go
back to the map and so we can kind of
see the distribution in stations around
the city I think this is almost all of
them as I was crop in the picture I
think a couple of maybe cuts off of the
top and they're well on each side
actually come to think of it so yeah
definitely when you go kind of out west
they seem to be a bit more scattered
around and I think you're right they're
definitely affect the results are we
hoping that you know this day's for you
able to the public I imagine the council
probably have people in house you have
access to all the historical data maybe
on their own the kind of bike level as
well which am maybe they would consider
publicizing at some point yeah any more
questions oh yeah Rania hi
so could you say the first bit
I definitely make my code look cleaner
in case any of you look at it because I
might get crucified later it's oh the
the gathering was pretty simple the one
thing I would change at she will be the
weather API used I didn't Yahoo weathers
the greatest like I should've mentioned
I could work for utilities company so
like I'm used to looking at weather data
and like I know there are better sources
out there than Yahoo weather especially
for places in um outside of the US
weather day it can be not the best like
I have an app on my phone I got rid of
it actually cuz it's so bad
think of Zacky weather something like
that and it would always tell me like oh
it's not raining it's sunny or something
and it was always of course it was
bloody raining so it didn't last too
long but yeah like I think some like met
Aaron historical data but it's the
source of any of access to through work
like it and it's only because we're
utilities company weather affects quite
a lot of what we do as far as part of
weather days ago probably spend a bit
more time from the fine and good source
of it really probably Weather
Underground I mean my go-to for anyone
thinking about using weather day for
their projects
number a round of applause and actually
all of our speakers thank you I really
enjoyed all of the clocks this evening